what's up Brian I wanted to know if you
could talk to JD about his finances his
wife on Instagram in front of the Golden
Gate Bridge is wearing a Gucci belt I
looked up the price of the belt and it's
$450 oh my god that was the whole
vacation your wife knows you're not a
millionaire right JD she wanted a Gucci
belt for and verse I did I got it for an
anniversary present and I accidentally
bought the wrong one I bought the more
expensive one you spent 400 bucks on a
belt yeah it was the more expensive one
JD it's fine you know a JD we're gonna
talk after this yeah I'm gonna come into
a little booth here we're gonna spend
five 10 minutes together talking
man-to-man okay you mind it's fine why
would you do that because I can you
saving money yeah you know I keep tabs
on this kid oh here we go
he left a 30% tip at a takeout place
that didn't even require to take out
take out this I know about coming home
people report to me I didn't say
anything what are you doing giving 30%
for takin oh okay people deserve a tip
but you know rocket I usually do 20 I
don't remember doing 30 somewhere but
whatever that's just a breast Chipotle a
rubber burner someone's going over my
receipts now so I just I keep tabs on
you guys went to Napa for the
anniversary okay and you're going on the
wine tour next month wait a minute they
went to Napa for the anniversary and she
got a Gucci belt and they're going now
in another wine tour hey listen you got
a safe for the future I was trying to be
nice okay be nice I mean when Howard
first started in radio he wasn't buying
anybody a Gucci belt a Gucci anything it
was fake I'll tell you what when I was
in high school you know what I wore a
movado watch and people would say ban I
didn't know you were rich my dad got
three Movado watches for ten bucks on
the street from and they were all fakes
but they ran for a year and my father
was like so hmm told you for $10 you got
three watches
any please if it we don't want to spend
like all this money or whatever it's
just like one thing is JD putting this
on credit or these cash purchases uh
both
I could pay off my credit card right now
if I wanted to why don't you feel
comfortable having the money in the bank
yeah but listen to me
this is again another thing I gotta talk
it's the whole thing credit card
companies are charging you don't I pay
above the limit every month now listen
to me you're not paying off your bill
because you feel comfortable giving
credit what kind of financial planning
is this okay listen it is guy he likes
having debt you like paying 18% good all
in your money okay
what's the interest rate on your credit
card oh I don't even know well there's
the problem what is going why are you
why are you my constantly getting [ __ ]
with like this because you put your
pictures on Instagram with bug and Gucci
bag okay showing off all your wealth
Moochie belt okay good wine country I'm
just worried about you I'm the one who
loves you remember that okay you want
love come here all right I feel so loved
right now who's your daddy yeah and what
does he do
[Laughter]